older white guy rubbing Bud Light on his
face
[Music]
people haul in a Bud Light keg
the guy keeps dropping light what a
bunch of goofy dumb stupid pick idiot
room Bud Light drinkers I keep stumbling
and falling now it's kind of windy oh
look at this dummy you can't even get to
a hammock
yo this guy can't even they've got to
know how to tap a keg that stupid Bud
Light drinkers
there we go we got more
middle-aged white guys I don't know what
the commercial is trying to tell you
other than middle-aged white guys and
kind of fratty looking guys the two main
constituencies for Bud Light uh they're
just a bunch of stupid klutzy idiots now
buy our beard dummies